What would you say would be
the learning curve of learning Angular?
The learning curve is actually
kind of like jagged for
Angular because there's
many levels of Angular.
The way I like to think about learning
framework is you learn it as a user so
you know how to use it very, very well.
But then you learn it as a developer
where you actually know how it works and
you contribute to it.
So on the user side it was
pretty straight forward.
It was kind of steep at first,
and might have had to do with
my skills in JavaScript and generally,
they were not that good at the time.
But I like to think of it as, actually
the less you know is probably better
because Angular introduces
a lot of new concepts.
And if you don't have to unlearn
something to learn Angular,
it's probably a lot easier.
But the learning curve was, I guess
it depends on how you go at it if you
read books and stuff it's going to
be kind of jagged, you're going to
read this blog that says do it this way,
and this blog says this way.
But actually, if you just dive right
in and start building stuff with it,
you'll realize that it's actually not
that difficult, it's pretty straight
forward and you can probably get
an app done in a couple hours.
So just keep building with it.
And the on the developer side,
learning how Angular works internally,
being able to contribute to it,
that just took forever.
[LAUGH] I mean I literally had to take
Angular apart, rebuild it from scratch,
and all types of stuff to
really understand how it works.
>> What are some recurring
job script techniques or
concepts that you found most
useful when learning a framework?
>> With this day and
age for sure is modules.
Having some type of module
pattern in JavaScript.
Because on the web every line of code
you write is going to be in a global
scope and that's just not good.
So, frameworks introduce some type of
module pattern to encapsulate your code.
So adopting that pattern whether it's
through the framework or using something
like ES6 or your own module pattern,
that's definitely a way to go.
I'm totally used to writing
everything in modules.
That's one thing, another thing
is get used to understanding how
component architecture work because
every framework that's going to come up
from here out is going to be
using a component architecture.
Which is based off of the web
component standard that's going to
be standard real soon.
So, just wrapping your head
around modules and components
is just going to leap you bounds towards
mastering all things web development.